now
dop leader sir jeffrey john donaldson
has urged boris johnson to prioritize
the political crisis in northern ireland
over controversies in downing street
earlier this week northern ireland's
first minister resigned over the
government's failure to address unionist
concerns about the brexit border in the
irish sea
city donaldson said the fallout from
lockdown parties number 10 was making it
difficult for the prime minister to
focus
he's been speaking to our senior ireland
correspondent david blevins
boris johnson promised your party there
would never be a border in the irish sea
then he promised to remove that border
why do you still trust him at all
well the prime minister did led us down
and led us down badly and at the
conservative party conference this year
i met the prime minister he apologized
to me the problem david is that we've
had a lot of words about triggering
article 16 which the protocol
allows the government to do in
circumstances whether it's economic or
societal or political harm caused by the
protocol and yet we haven't had any
action i've asked for a commitment that
if we don't get agreement article 16
will be triggered and the uk government
will take unilateral action to
honor the commitment the prime minister
gave to honor the commitment the
government gave at the restoration of
our devolved institutions that they
would take steps to introduce
legislation to protect northern
ireland's police within the uk and they
have failed to do that that is why i
have acted now
so you've acted the agriculture minister
from your party halted checks we know
that's not subject to judicial review
but if a minister in the devolved
government had the power to halt brexit
checks
how did westminster have the power to
remove northern ireland from the
european union in the first place well
because the people of the united kingdom
voted for all of the united kingdom to
leave the european union but doesn't
that mean the government of the united
kingdom alone has the power to either
halt or continue brexit checks i believe
that the government of the united
kingdom does have the power under
article 16 of the protocol to take
unilateral action to protect northern
ireland's place within the uk and to
protect the integrity of the uk internal
market and i'm saying to them very
clearly that if and i want to see
political stability in northern ireland
david i've worked for decades for
political stability that is my objective
but we can't have political stability
when the concerns of unionists are being
completely ignored when this protocol is
harming our relationship with the rest
of the uk and the government is failing
to act
when do you want to see the stormont
election and if the dup
doesn't win that election are you
prepared to nominate a deputy first
minister and cia shin fan first minister
well it is a matter for the secretary of
state for northern ireland to decide the
timing of the election
we will be ready to take our case to the
people as soon as that election is
called in terms of the outcome of the
election david i want unionism to win i
am not contemplating uh defeat uh at the
hands of sinn fein my objective is to
win the support of people in northern
ireland to maintain um the dup and
unionism as the largest block in the
northern ireland assembly that's what i
want to achieve and i think in those
circumstances we will have a unionist
first minister so what do you say to
people who would fear that the dup will
just use the protocol right to prevent
sharing power with sinn fein
i'm committed to devolution i am
committed to sharing power with other
parties in northern ireland
but we cannot go on with a situation
where the views and concerns of unionism
and unionist parties in northern are
being ignored i want to restore fairness
i want to restore respect i want to
restore political stability in northern
ireland but that means the protocol has
to be dealt with solutions need to be
found and the sooner that happens the
better and i hope that before the
assembly election david we will get an
agreement uh on uh dealing with the
problems and resolving
the difficulties created by this rec
border the ousting of arling foster
revealed division in the dup the parties
had three leaders unlike two first
ministers in the space of ten months is
the party in meltdown i don't think that
it is david we're um preparing for the
election i've worked hard since i became
leader of the dup and to heal the wounds
um like every political party from time
to time um the dup has its differences
sadly last year those differences became
a very public affair
and i deeply regret that that happened
and i am working
to pull the party together and get the
party into shape to fight the election
and win the election for unionism so
geoffrey the founder of this party the
reverend ian paisley
would not have been impressed by boozy
parties in downing street
why is the dup the only opposition party
not calling for the prime minister's
resignation
well to be clear we have spoken out very
strongly
and i think that one of the most
passionate speeches that we've seen
in the house of commons was that of my
colleague jim shannon the member of
parliament for strangford who spoke
powerfully about the experience of his
family losing his mother-in-law
during the covent pandemic
but i would say this to the prime
minister
northern ireland is an important part of
the united kingdom
you're our prime minister and if you
want to
build confidence
then
do what other prime ministers did in the
past recognize that we have a serious
problem here and instead of being
focused on
what's going on in downing street be the
prime minister the people needs reach
out to northern ireland help us to
resolve these issues make this a
priority let's get
our political institutions restored on
the basis
of sound foundations that means dealing
with the protocol making these issues a
priority so that the people of northern
ireland
can enjoy strong stable government
that's what we expect of a prime
minister we can't go on like this david
we can't go on with the situation where
serious problems like we have here in
northern are not getting the attention
they deserve those are strong words from
a unionist party leader are you
suggesting that boris johnson
has made northern ireland such
a low priority that the peace process is
effectively being damaged i'm saying
that all of the controversy surrounding
um
downing street is making it difficult
for the prime minister to focus on what
needs to get priority i recognize the
situation for example in ukraine is
critical i recognize that getting the uk
out of uh covert and and into a more
normal situation and the recovery of our
economy and are supporting our health
service are important but so is northern
ireland and whilst i welcome very much
the commitment of liz trust
to drive forward the negotiations it
disappoints me that our prime minister
cannot give a firm commitment
today
that if
there is not agreement reached uh with
the european union he will take the
steps that are necessary to restore
northern ireland's place within the uk
internal market that means triggering
article or 16. that's the commitment i
need to get from this prime minister and
if he doesn't give it to you there's not
going to be a power sharing government
regardless of what happens during the
election well if the prime minister
as i do cherishes the union
and i believe that the prime minister is
a unionist
then he needs to recognize that right
now northern ireland um
there are
serious problems here that need to be
addressed i want the prime minister to
give that priority i want the prime
minister to give a firm commitment no
more words we need action here in
northern ireland sir jeffrey donaldson
thank you very much